I was looking at your IMDB profile and
it says you have four movies coming out
this year including the intruder oh you
have the time like how did you do this
all I'm independent god you know what me
I'm just we worked really hard man ya
know and don't live in Hollywood that's
one big thing because I feel like you
know I'm really just about to work you
know I mean I'm really I love film and I
love cinema and you know for me just as
a black filmmaker one of the biggest
things is you know how do you how do you
just make movies without an order of the
stuff you know like without someone
telling you what movie to make you know
I just wanted to do my own theme in and
it's a hard work it's hard work you know
yeah but it's but it's but when you get
to a moment like this you know as an
independent filmmaker man this is where
you go man I got a blast you know like
you have so many hard hardships you know
like not being able to put gas in your
car or you know waking up like man I'm
pay my rent or you know just a homemaker
and then when you get to the point to
what you put it all into a film and it
has this type of result you know when
someone like Sony comes in like yo we
you know why God kind of puts you
through these little things so you can
learn and have a stage like this well
how did you get the intruder off the
ground like what was the process so so
for us it was um we would I was looking
to make a thriller yeah
mark Berger who created saw big fan of
me as a filmmaker it was like mad got a
great script for you okay so they gave
me the script and I read it and I
remember going like man this is really
good
mm-hm and I remember having all these
ideas and for me as a filmmaker whenever
I can every page I turn I'm seeing it
yeah I said that's the movie for me you
know and he gave it to me I gave the
script to rocks in my producing partner
and I was like Rob we got to make this
movie and we call Robert Smith who's
been financed and some of the stuff for
us and was like please mr. Smith
like if you could just give us a couple
million dollars I think this is a great
film and he was I do believe it and I
say yeah I do
and we were off to the races and we shot
this movie in 24 days oh my god
I wrote Dennis Quaid a letter he
responded to my letter mmm which was
like already like what's happening now
he called me on the phone and you know
for me you know it was the first time I
reminded myself of my mom right Dennis
Quaid Karma's like God and I was going
like this is I've never run through the
house like you always do screaming help
and you know and he was like oh but I'm
like he's just way over the phone so I
talked to him on the phone and he was
just like man I love this you don't want
to do it and I want to do it do it and
when you know you get that type of
energy man you just go with it and he is
epic yeah I mean he's crazy a mess dude
he is epic I had a chance to go watch
the movie with an audience
mm-hmm and just standing on the screen
you know Daniel Pearl shot the movie who
did Texas Chainsaw Massacre and to just
drive back into this world of horror
with Dennis Quaid man like this opposite
some black people I was at aw man this
is like are you kidding me
so it just all come collides together it
all collides together no it's it's such
a blessing man I'm just happy like
people are responding and you know just
for all the independent filmmakers man
this is like this is a beautiful moment
you know like I represent the people
that have hoped and want to make movies
and Here I am you know sitting here like
with a bunch of passion and hope and
here's my movie I was gonna say there's
such an interactive element to the movie
you get the audience last night they
were going crazy yes do you prepare for
that when you're shooting it yeah
anything you want you because that's my
personality
I would love they're like dump myself
into the film like what would I scream
at what would I yell at like what would
I be like girl you tripping right like
you are tripping right now right and
it's funny because people are in the
theater doing that
like that's what makes the movie great
economy especially now man with so much
chaos in the world it's just great man
to be able to go to the theater turn
your phone off eat popcorn and be like
yo this is entertaining yes man exactly
thank you